الاجانب ومتزوجوا الجنسيه من ذوي الاصول
الايرانيه حولهم النظام في طهران الى ورقه
ابتزاز تلوح بها امام الحكومه الاجنبيه
اخر هذه الاوراق حكم اصدرته سلطات
الايرانيه يقضي بسجن عامل الاغاثه
البلجيكي اولمبيه فان ديكاستين لمده 28
عاما بعد اعتقاله في فبراير الماضي بتهم
التجسس وهي الاتهامات التي تنفيها السلطات
البلجيكيه وعائله المدان بقوه بلجيكا ترى
في قضيه عامر الاغاثه والحكم الصادر في
حقه وسيله ضغط الايرانيه على بلجيكا
لاطلاق صلاح الدبلوماسيه الايراني اسد
الله اسدي المحكوم ب 20 سنه بالسجن في
بلجيكا على خلفيه ادانته بالتخطيط لهجوم
على تجمعا للمعارضه الايرانيه في فرنسا
عام 2018 خطوه ايرانيه تاتي بعد اسبوع من
تعليق المحكمه الدستوريه في بلجيكا معاهده
لتبادل السجناء مع ايران والتي انتظروا ان
يصدر الحكم النهائي في مدى شرعيتها خلال
ثلاثه اشهر معتبره محللون انه رد غاضب من
ايران بعد هذا التعليق وان كان مؤقتا